Mike judge create the show yes and I was
realizing he's got I mean the guy has
made so many amazing shows he started
with beavis and butt-head heard of it
right and then but also king of the hill
you know he's got a see the the
prophetic documentary that's now
occurring
yes exactly idiocracy I mean what's it
like working with the guy Mike judge
himself cuz I don't really know
he's a bit of an HR nightmare and yet he
calls people names and pushes people
down physically but no he's so a super
nice guy it's one of the things that I
was I don't know impressed with his
wrong word but just sort of like oh
that's a model citizen of way of how to
do it if he's like he's rich and famous
super successful but still like a
down-to-earth good old boy yeah
very few of us can pull it off it's true
and occasionally I'll like I'll like
walk around set and you know be like
this is the coolest thing I've ever seen
in my life try to do you know just do it
and do it and occasionally I can sucker
him into also doing a voice talking back
in Beavis and Butthead Butthead or Hank
Hill or something and I'm always like he
does a really good Butthead and then
you're like oh yeah that's but yeah he
is yeah yeah but his his regular
speaking voice is somewhere in the to in
between Butthead and Hank Hill it was
just sort of like if he likes to take
he'll come in his be like that was
fantastic
he's got this sort of chuckle II kind of
laugh yeah great
and I tickle him and I grab him sounds
like you're the HR nightmare right
you